well it was just so weird like Benji
comes in okay now Ben she wants to give
Richard and saliheen job to see who you
know who will grow within two seconds
there's always a problem he's like I
wanted oil I didn't want lotion lotion
take what you get buddy and then the
next problem was he with the headphones
he had a switch headphones right Gary
like all of a sudden he gives me the
signal I need the volume up then he
gives me saying I need the volume down
then he can't hear that I realize even
though I put his headphones on correctly
somehow one of the ears has gotten
twisted up so I can't hear I mean why is
it no one has a problem but Benji then
in the middle he needs to switch
microphones so then he needs to switch
the handheld with Richard and the
switching headphones and everything's
tangled it was insane so funny you offer
Benji a ride the other day Gary was
going out to Long Island and then she
wanted to go with him oh and I said why
would you ever get started with Benji
and and Gary was telling me within two
seconds in the car Benji's already
carsick people who you're doing a favor
yeah who make your life miserable you
know you should never get started with
Benji I'm on the cross on the Parkway
and I look in my rearview mirror and I
hear this very tiny little eyes but I
see Benji going he's pulling his face as
far apart as he can is going give me
that noise again yeah okay so what's
with him I go what's going on he goes
you know what's going on you haven't
paid attention to him for five minutes
he goes I'm getting carsick of course
okay fair enough I go would you like me
to pull over he goes no I'll be okay
it's just gonna be a brutal ride from
here in oh great like an hour and a half
every once in a while we're just here
we're just here like he had a very
difficult ride right he had a very
difficult day and he doesn't know how to
deal with it no I told to open the
window then of course now I'm wondering
is he gonna barf in my car god I would
have put him in the trunk like in The
Sopranos Benji get out and walk like
like my parents used to say when I was
annoying it get out
get out of the car they pull out run the
Southern State Parkway I would be like
10 you shouldn't do that to a 10 year
old I'm overweight 50 Roca needs to walk
good it is interesting I put them in a
horse trail okay Benji I'll give you a
ride but let me get let me let me put
the hedgehog I didn't understand the
pulling on the face thing he was just
like me doesn't fit around me look at me